Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 139. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ihr seid wieder auf dem Kanal, wo viel gereist wird. Nicht zu unrecht heißt das Programm hier Express, was sich dieses Jahr ganz gut bewahrheitet hat und heute ist es mal wieder soweit. Bin gerade frisch aus dem Nachtzug gefallen, um die unglaubliche Strecke bis nach Kölns rückzulegen. Ich hoffe, ich bin wach genug für diese Sendung, aber nach dem vierten Kaffee geht's mittlerweile und ja, auch mein Gegenüber macht mittlerweile einen ganz wachen Eindruck. Von daher bin ich ganz zuversichtlich, dass wir hier das Thema Medienkompetenz ganz gut einkreisen können, denn darum soll es heute gehen. Netznutzung, Entwicklung der Medien und der Umgang von Informationen. Ich habe mir das Thema schon mal länger auf die Liste geschrieben und dachte mir immer so, das müsste man doch mal irgendwie behandeln. Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht so linear erforscht, wie irgendwelche APs oder sonst welche konkreten technischen Zusammenhänge, aber um das Ganze dann doch vielleicht mal ein bisschen auf den Punkt zu bringen, dachte ich mir, rede ich mal mit Torsten. Torsten Kleinz, hallo.
Guten Morgen.
Willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Du bist, was bist du eigentlich? Du bist...
Ja, ich bin in erster Linie freie Journalist, dann Blogger. Seit sieben Jahren ich beschäftige mich mit allem, was mit Internet zu tun hat, was mittlerweile ein sehr breites Feld ist. Früher war es ein sehr kleines Spezialgebiet und ich beobachte sehr gerne, wie quasi diese Geekkultur quasi auf die gesamte Gesellschaft übergreift und wie sich die digitalen Medien auf den Alltag auswirken. Erst von einem kleinen Kreis, jetzt von neben.
Ja, du bist auch bekennender Nerd. Zumindest hast du dich so intensiv mit dem Thema beschäftigt, wie ich mir dachte, dass eigentlich nur ein Nerd sich damit beschäftigen kann, weil wer sich so mit Nerds beschäftigt, ist selbst Nerd.
Ich glaube, da habe ich einen ähnlichen Status wie du. Du wolltest dich ja auch nicht selbst als Nerd bezeichnen. Kurze Erläuterung, ich hatte Tim Pritlove vor einiger Zeit zum Thema Nerds interviewt und hier, das ist wahrscheinlich eine kleine Retourkutsche.
Ich wollte mich nicht als Nerd bezeichnen?
Das habe ich nicht so gesagt. Doch.
Das habe ich so gesagt? Aber das hast du nicht so ins Endprodukt reingeschnitten. Also es ist nicht wahr.
Ich schneide eh nicht.
Nur, was die Medien am Ende berichten, ist wahr. Das wissen wir doch.
Genau. Was in der Zeitung steht, ist richtig und jeden Tag passiert genauso viel, wie in eine Zeitung reinpasst. Das ist immer wieder faszinierend.
Das stimmt. Und nicht mehr?
Nicht mehr, nee. Sonst passiert nichts. Ja.
Ich bin schon Nerd.
Okay.
Auf meine Art. Jeder ist, glaube ich, so Nerd auf seine Art. Aber du hast ja auch Geekkultur gesagt. Was ist denn das für dich, die Geekkultur? Ich meine, wo fängt das an?
Dadurch, dass ich mich jetzt, ich glaube mein Nerd-Blog ist jetzt sieben Jahre alt, dadurch, dass ich mich so lange damit beschäftige, fällt es mir unheimlich schwer, da eine Definition zu finden.
Geeks, dass, was für ein Nerd-Blog, dass es dieses Nerd ist?
Ja, oder Web 2.0 ist, wo ich das Blog heißt 3Live, wo ich dann angefangen habe, einfach nur Klischees zu sammeln und das Schlimme ist, je billiger das Klischee war, desto mehr Leute kamen und sagten, hey, das ist genau bei mir so und wenn ich sage, du suchst per Google deine Hosen aus, kommen plötzlich 15 Leute zu sagen, ja, das habe ich gestern gemacht.
Echt, ich habe mir noch nie bei Google meine Hosen ausgesucht.
Ja, das war jetzt ein übertriebenes Beispiel, aber es gab sehr kuriose Begegnungen, wo ich mit Klischee und Realität gespielt habe und dann von der Realität sehr überrascht wurde.
Eingeholt wurde es sozusagen sogar auch.
Ja, beziehungsweise ich habe die Realität vorher anders wahrgenommen.
Du meinst, die Nerds sind noch nerdiger als das Klischee behauptet?
In anderen Bereichen. Also, Nerds müssten nicht, dieses Nerd-Klischee ist ja der fettige Haare ungepflegt und so weiter und so fort. Damit kann man Nerds heute überhaupt nicht mehr erkennen. Okay, nur noch zum Teil. Aber das Wichtige ist eine Lebensweise, eine Art neugierig zu sein, eine Art mit Dingen umzugehen und auch mit Medien umzugehen. Und da kommen wir jetzt, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen ins Thema. Nerds und Geeks sind quasi die, die Microplogging erfunden haben. Und jetzt sehen wir, was bei Twitter herauskommt, wenn quasi die gesamte Welt diesen Kommunikationskanal benutzt.
Einen Nerd-Kanal benutzt.
Ja, beziehungsweise ist er jetzt noch ein Nerd-Kanal. Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin mir auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher, ob das jeder einer war. Ich meine, Twitter, jetzt greifen wir schon so ein bisschen vorweg, aber ich meine, das Ganze ist so... Ich finde, du hast schon recht, es ist so ein bisschen nerdig gestartet. Nämlich so diese Idee mit, ja, ich schreib jetzt mal, was mein Status ist und das können dann andere, ja, verfolgen. Allein schon so was wie einen Status zu haben, ist ja schon an sich eine recht nerdige Geschichte. Nur ist denen das ja dann auch entglitten und ist ja was anderes draus geworden. Also es war ja nie als Kommunikationsmedium im eigentlichen Sinne gedacht.
Ja.
Zumindest nicht als, komischerweise, passte am Ende des Ergebnisses mehr zu dem Namen als ihre ursprüngliche Idee.
Ja, also über die massive Einbindung von Links, die Nerds haben das Was-tust-du ignoriert, haben Links gepostet, haben retweetet und so weiter und quasi die Kommunikationskanäle geschaffen, die Twitter heute ausmachen.
Aber wir wollten ja eigentlich so ein bisschen weiter ausholen und nicht nur über Twitter reden. Stichwort ist Medienkompetenz, ein Begriff, der, ich hab keine Ahnung seit wann der schon in der Runde ist, mir kommt es so ein bisschen vor ewig. Ich weiß auch nicht, wer den erfunden hat, am Ende war es mal war Holland, ich weiß es nicht. Könnte man jetzt einfach mal so behaupten. Tatsache ist, es ging, und das war ja auch schon immer so ein bisschen die Antwort, auch der aufgeklärten Computernutzer, ich will jetzt mal nicht so sehr auf diesen Begriff Nordrumme reiten, die die Technologie sehr wach und auch von Anfang an ja positivistisch begleitet haben, gesagt haben, na ja, alles hat so Chancen und Risiken. Und klar, man kann jetzt die ganze Zeit immer alles verteufeln und ganz furchtbar finden. Ich würde das ja bei vielen Sachen, die so einmal in Mainstream-Schwappen beobachten kann. Aber es kann ja auch irgendwie, nicht alles ist schlecht. So locker gesagt. Und der Begriff Medienkompetenz war dann eigentlich so ein bisschen auch der Sammelbegriff für die Antwort nach dem Motto, was beschwert ihr euch, wenn ihr euch nur ein bisschen länger damit beschäftigt, dann werdet ihr das schon irgendwie ins Hirn kriegen und dann wird das für euch normal. Und dann werdet ihr sehen, dass die Sonne scheint und das Gras sprießt und der Himmel ist blau und das wird dann alles ganz toll. Jetzt die Frage natürlich, wie weit sind wir denn da jetzt vorangekommen? Gibt es elektronische Medien, über die man sinnvoll kommunizieren kann? Gibt es, technisch betrachtet seit Anfang der 80er Jahre, real in diese Gesellschaft gekommen? Ist es wahrscheinlich erst Mitte der 90er? So mit dem ersten Web-Boom, denke ich mal, ist das so ein bisschen angekommen. Und seit Anfang 2000 fängt das an, sich so langsam zu verfestigen. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen dein Einstiegszeitpunkt gewesen. Ich weiß nicht, was hast du vorher gemacht? Du bist nicht direkt ins Internet hineingeboren worden?
Nein, ich komme quasi ganz vom Lande. Damals hatte ich nur einen Amiga 500 zu Hause und konnte darüber. Ich habe den nicht als Kommunikationsmaschine benutzen können. Dann bin ich nach Köln gekommen, um mein Studium zu beginnen. Da wurde mir auf der Messe von einer Amiga-Userin gezeigt, was man mit einem Mode machen kann. Das war für mich eine Offenbarung. Weil die neuen Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten und die Informationsfülle, auf die man zugreifen konnte, also vorher habe ich tatsächlich Videotext gelesen und das für eine sehr gute Idee gehalten. Weil da konnte ich mich abseits der 20 Uhr Tagesschau und abseits der Lokalnachrichten in der Zeitung, die einmal am Tag kam, aktuell informieren. Und als ich dann erstmal einen Frauser gesehen habe, E-Mail gesehen habe, dachte ich, das ist es. Das ist ein, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich sofort gesagt habe, das ist die Zukunft. Aber ich habe gesehen, das ist meine Zukunft. Weil diese Vielfalt der Informationswege, damit umzugehen und mich damit zu beschäftigen, das war, glaube ich, sofort klar, dass ich das machen will.
Also hast du schon so diesen klassischen Aha-Effekt gehabt, so oh boah, was ist das denn?
Auf alle Fälle.
Oh mein Gott, it's full of stars.
Und damit gleichzeitig habe ich auch mein Studium an der Journalistenschule begonnen. Von daher bin ich auch sehr in die journalistische Ecke dann gleich reingekommen.
Und bist dann dann auch schnell, sagen wir mal, zu so einer Art Internetjournalisten geworden. Das Netz ist dein Thema. Es gibt viele Szenen, die du auch ein bisschen enger begleitet hast. Das ist zumindest jetzt aus der Ferne meine Wahrnehmung. Wikipedia gehört dazu. Das ist etwas, was du eigentlich von Anfang an schon im Fokus gehabt hast, bevor da überhaupt irgendjemand nennenswert drüber geschrieben hat. Gab es noch so ein anderes Steckenpferd, wo du sich so ein bisschen mehr drauf gestürzt hast?
Auch einige Demoszenen zum Beispiel. Ich hab mich ein bisschen mit E-Sport beschäftigt. So allgemein die verschiedenen Computerszenen zu betrachten ist so ein kleines Hobby von mir. Ab und zu gucke ich in ganz verwegene Foren, um zu sehen, wie funktioniert die Kommunikation dort. Wenn ich zum Beispiel in einem Kochforum reingucke und sehe, dass die zwar andere Abkürzungen verwenden, wo dann plötzlich steht MG, MG, und dann sucht man und sucht und erfährt, das ist mein Göttergatter. Und das ist völlig abstrukt.
Was bei den Geeks SO heißt.
Aha, was heißt SO? Ach ja, ich dachte, das ist eher das allgemeine Englische. Gut, jedenfalls diese Gemeinsamkeiten und diese Unterschiede zu betrachten ist höchst faszinierend. Weil ob Usenet, ob Kochforum, es gibt teilweise immer dieselben Mechanismen, wie sich Informationen verbreiten, wie sich Communities entwickeln, wie Informationen weiterverbreitet werden. Dass man, wenn man einige dieser Regeln kennt, diese allgemeinen Regeln kennt, sich quasi in fast jede Community sofort reinfinden kann.
Aber wenn du jetzt über diese Szenen berichtet hast, was sind so deine Premiere-Outlets? Du schreibst relativ viel bei Heise.
Ja, ich schreibe für Focus Online, Zeit Online, ab und zu auch für Printmagazine, Frankfurter Rundschau, was sich halt so bietet.
Okay, also du hast sowohl den Nachrichten-Part, als auch so die längeren Reviews. Wenn du also jetzt darauf blickst und darüber berichtest, wo hast du dann sozusagen dein journalistisches Rüstzeug her? Hast du das jetzt aus dem Studium bekommen? Oder hast du dann tatsächlich was im Netz gelernt, wie man damit umgehen kann? Also kann das Netz und war das Netz für dich eine Quelle für journalistisches Handeln in irgendeiner Form?
Auf jeden Fall 100 Prozent. Im Internet kann man Recherchen anstellen, die früher wirklich nur über sehr große Umwege zu ermitteln waren. Beispiel, als ich an der Journalistenschule aufgenommen wurde, gab es eine Rechercheübung, wo wir beweisen mussten, dass wir Informationen recherchieren können. Und eine meiner Aufgaben war, eine Zahl von den Kölner Verkehrsbetrieben herauszubekommen. Damals bei diesem Einstufungstest haben wir in eine Jugendherberge gewohnt und da gab es eine Telefonzelle. Und dann sind einige zwei Haltestellen weitergefahren, um eine andere Telefonzelle zu erreichen. Und dort haben wir dann versucht, diese Informationen zu ermitteln. Heute wäre das eine Google-Abfrage fünf Sekunden fertig. Und mit diesen unglaublichen Möglichkeiten umgehen zu können, ist quasi für jeden Journalisten heute Pflicht. Und teilweise ist es deprimierend, wie wenig es manche können. Teilweise ist es auch unheimlich faszinierend zu sehen, welche Mechanismen doch schon in der Breite angekommen sind.
Aber wenn es jetzt so einfach ist, dann müsste es ja eigentlich auch folgerichtig viel mehr Leuten gelingen, gut journalistisch zu arbeiten. Hast du den Eindruck, dass die journalistische Qualität und Quantität insgesamt zunimmt?
Das Problem ist, dass die Vereinfachung dafür gesorgt hat, dass der Journalist sehr viel mehr Aufgaben übernehmen muss. Er muss nicht mehr nur recherchieren und schreiben. Teilweise ist es in den USA auch beneidenswert so, dass sie getrennte Schreiber und Rechercheure haben, was in Deutschland nie, jedenfalls nicht in der Breite so gewesen ist. Sondern heutzutage muss ein Journalist sich ums Layout sorgen. Er muss gleichzeitig auch für Community-Support sorgen. Er bekommt die Leserbriefe direkt auf den Schreibtisch. Von daher wird einem viel der Möglichkeiten, die durch das Internet gegeben werden, auch wieder weggenommen, weil das Zeitbudget sinkt, um tatsächlich zu recherchieren.
Ich meine, hast du auch deine Leserbriefe an? Liest du deine heiße Forum-Einträge zu deinen Artikeln?
Ich haue auf alle Fälle in die Foren rein. Allerdings, wenn tausend Beiträge sind, kann ich natürlich nicht alle lesen. Es gibt bestimmte Code-Worte, worauf man achtet. Wenn da zum Beispiel Ed Heiser als Überschrift steht, dann ist da mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Tippfehler, den ich gemacht habe. Da muss ich auch ein bisschen das Heiser Forum verteidigen, was sehr oft als reine Ansammlung von sehr besserwisserischen Menschen gesehen wird, was es de facto auch ist. Aber man kann tatsächlich noch Informationen daraus extrahieren, die einem sehr weiterhelfen, auch als Journalist.
Ist das dann nicht mit allen Foren so? Aber ich meine, hat sich jetzt beim Heiser Forum konkret irgendwas Spezifisches herausgebildet, was man jetzt da besonders wertschätzen sollte?
Doch das Heiser Forum, sagen wir es mal so, es ist quasi die Entwicklung, die viele Communities gehabt haben, zum Beispiel auch Wikipedia. Es ist primär mal entstanden als, ja, schreibt eure Kommentare zu den Artikeln. Und für manche Menschen ist daraus ein Lebensraum geworden. Und daraus haben sich auch Initiativen gebildet. Ganz früher gab es dann diese Organisation, Stopp 1984 oder No 1984, die sich aus dem Heisefrohung gebildet hat und die auch eine der Vorläufer-Organisationen, korrigiere mich, wenn ich falsch liege, vom AK Vorrat war.
Das liegt zeitlich davor, ja. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie der direkte Zusammenhang einzelner war.
Aber prinzipiell aus diesem Zweck gebundenen wurde dann ein Lebensraum. Das Internet ist generell ein Lebensraum geworden. Aber aus so zweckgebundenen Communities entwickeln sich Lebensräume. Man kriegt den Menschen nicht aus der Kommunikation raus. Wenn selbst sehr, sehr fachspezifische Foren haben dann plötzlich eine Alltagsecke, wo dann jemand fragen kann, wo kriege ich einen Gebrauchtwagen her? Ach, diese blöde GEZ. Und da habe ich wieder einen lustigen Catcontent gefunden.
Also mit Menschen kriegst du nicht raus. Du meinst, Einzelne setzen sich an diesen Kommunikationsorten einfach fest und sind dann da.
Ja.
Und fühlen sich da irgendwie wohl und betrachten dann auch die Neulinge als Eindringlinge. Und dann wird es schwierig?
Nicht nur. Das ist natürlich ein Aspekt davon. Aber es sind auch nicht nur Leute, die sich festsetzen, sondern ein Neuling kommt in ein Forum und fragt halt, was zu einem Thema ist. Dann kommt man aufs andere Thema und es entwickelt eine Eigendynamik. Kommunikation ist etwas sehr Menschliches und die Menschen mit all ihren Fehlern bzw. mit all ihren komischen Eigenarten prägen Kommunikationskanäle, die ganz anders gedacht waren.
Mir fällt es immer wieder auf, insbesondere jetzt auf Twitter, wenn gerade mal wieder eine Welle, eine Skandalwelle durchs Netz prescht und ganz viel Aufregung herrscht. Dann bist du dann nicht selten einer von denen, die als erstes den Finger heben und sagen, habt ihr euch das mal genau durchgelesen und das stimmt doch alles gar nicht und das ist doch schon seit acht Wochen widerlegt. Worüber redet ihr eigentlich? Welche Erfahrungen machst du denn sozusagen in der Wahrnehmung dessen, was andere Leute berichten?
Es ist manchmal deprimierend. Twitter ist ein sehr schönes Beispiel für Kommunikationsprozesse, die extrem beschleunigt wurden. Also die Dynamik eines Retweets, also diese Nachricht, diese kurze Nachricht, die immer weitergegeben wird, klingt sehr davon ab, wie sie formuliert wurde. Wenn ich den gleichen Sachverhalt einmal sehr sachlich formuliere und einmal dick Skandal davor schreibe, dann was wird sich weiter verbreiten, die Nachrichten mit dem Skandal davor, selbst wenn es kein Skandal ist. Dennoch würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass Twitter eine reine Skandalmaschine ist, sondern es ist quasi die Möglichkeit zu beobachten, wie Menschen sowieso kommunizieren. Wenn du tatsächlich dein Aufnahmegerät auf Weit- beziehungsweise als Richtmikrofon in der Kneipe einsetzen würdest, würdest du natürlich auch hören, wie Leute über die täglichen Nachrichten berichten, die relativ wenig mit Zeitungsberichterstattung zu tun haben. Die sagen dann nicht, GM präsentiert Pläne zur Opelsanierung, sondern, ach, die Amis, die werden uns jetzt ausnehmen, die haben uns ausgebotet. Und Twitter bietet einfach die Möglichkeit, Leute zu beobachten, wie sie funktionieren, wie sie sprechen, wie sie Informationen wahrnehmen.
Das echte Leben.
Ja, natürlich hat auch das Medium Einfluss darauf, wie Informationen sich weiterverbreiten. Also, wenn jetzt auf Twitter gibt es jetzt lauter Witze, beziehungsweise diese Texte, die sich auf der Startseite auch ansiedeln, wo dann...
Trending-Topics.
Genau. Die dann sehr häufig entweder die Revolution im Iran sind oder das neueste Witztopic, was man nicht beim ersten Date sagen sollte, oder du bist ein Liberal, wenn... Und dann ergänzt halt jeder in seinen 140 Zeichen.
Das Meme des Tages sozusagen.
Genau.
Und Michael Jackson natürlich.
Und man sieht natürlich sehr viel... Es gibt sehr viele Möglichkeiten. Es gibt Leute, die sich über Twitter dann zu einem Flashmob verabreden. Die meisten sagen aber nur ihre 30 Zeichen dazu und retweeten. Dann zu beobachten, wer tatsächlich kreativ damit umgeht und wer einfach nur nacherzählt bzw. ach, ich hab was Tolles gesehen, aber ich mach nichts Tolles damit. Das ist auch eine der interessanten Sachen, die man bei Twitter lernen kann. Wie wenig kreative Köpfe quasi die Kommunikation bestimmen.
Aber ist das noch eine große Überraschung? Also dass es immer so eine kleine Elite gibt, die jetzt wirklich die Perlen ausgräbt und dann vielleicht auch zu schätzen weiß?
Für mich ist es keine große Überraschung, aber es wird immer wieder übersehen. Wenn ich zurück an 1996 denke, welcher Internet-Enthusiasmus herrschte, ja, wir können uns alle informieren, wir sind nicht mehr auf Massenmedien angewiesen und diese blöden Gatekeeper, die uns Information vorteilten oder nach drei Wochen liefern, wenn ich die Informationen sehe, die sich auf Twitter verbreiten, das sind dann wieder die Informationen, die von Gatekeeper gefiltert wurden, wieder Informationen, die vor drei Wochen schon bekannt waren. Von daher...
Aber es gibt vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Gatekeeper als es noch. Dass es 96 gab.
Ist die Frage. Wir haben jetzt die Möglichkeit, uns nur mit Menschen zu umgeben, die absolut dieselben Interessen haben wie wir. Das ist eine große Falle der Informationsmedien. Ich habe mir heute Morgen tatsächlich noch mal eine Tageszeitung gekauft, was ich viel zu selten tue. Und ich habe tatsächlich wieder einige Informationen entdeckt, die für mich relevant sein könnten, die auf dem Bildschirm einfach nicht für mich sichtbar waren. Wie zum Beispiel jetzt auf der Kölner Stadtanzeigertitelseite das die Weihnachtsmärkte öffnen, gehe ich gerne mal vorbei, um mich mit ein paar Freunden auf ein Glühwein zu treffen. Das wird im Twitter nicht rüberkommen.
Local Shit. Local Shit nenne ich das immer so. Der unmittelbare Bericht aus meiner unmittelbaren Umgebung, die man so meistens nicht sieht. Man schaut immer so auf die großen Probleme über den Teich und was weiß ich, ins ganze Universum herein und freut sich, wie sehr man doch am Weltgeschehen teilhat. Aber man weiß halt nicht, was zwei Blogs weiter passiert. Und manchmal interessiert es einen doch mehr, als man vielleicht zuzugeben bereit ist. Ich habe übrigens auch gerade eine Zeitung wieder abonniert. Richtig mit Papier, die morgens über die Briefkasten steckt. Und so ist es großartig.
Ja, dass man noch zum Briefkasten gehen muss, ist noch das größte Problem. Aber einfach einen längeren Text zu lesen, der länger als 140 Zeichen lang ist, oder ein Thema über Wochen zu verfolgen, das geht teilweise sehr verloren in diesen sehr beschleunigten digitalen Kanälen. Man erinnere sich an diese ganze Euphorie in Twitter über Burma, wo sind die ganzen Blogger heute, die damals versprochen haben, wir werden uns jetzt auf ewig um das Thema kümmern und wir werden an der Sache dran bleiben. Entweder sind sie nicht mehr dran oder man liest sie einfach nicht mehr, weil wie lang ist das her? Das sind ja schon 50 Internetjahre her. Also das Kurzzeitgedächtnis ist extrem verstärkt und das Langzeitgedächtnis der Community als solches existiert kaum noch. Was man nicht bei Google zurückwärts finden kann, das ist schon nicht mehr geschehen. Beispiel, da können auch professionelle Medien auch noch ein Gegengewicht bieten, ist die Frage, inwieweit sie es noch tun. Also, dass ich jetzt bei Personalabbau nach Personalabbau noch ein Redakteur komplett um eine Firma kümmern kann, ist schon wieder real geworden, weil er zu viel anderes zu tun hat. Bei Heiser habe ich jetzt über fünf oder sechs Jahre kontinuierlich über Wikipedia berichtet. Und nur dadurch ist es mir quasi möglich gewesen, tatsächlich sehr auf dem aktuellen Stand zu sein, welche Diskussionen es gibt, welche Ansätze es gibt. Was mir als Blogger nicht möglich gewesen wäre, einfach mich so oft darum zu kümmern, ohne jetzt quasi mein ganzes Leben in Wikipedia zu verbringen und irgendwo anders das Geld herzuschaffen.
Bevor wir in die nächste Untiefe mit Wikipedia eintauchen, wollte ich nochmal ein bisschen zurückrollen. Wir sind ja so ein bisschen bei der Recherche jetzt eigentlich gestartet und drohen jetzt schon wieder auf dem Twitter-Teppich auszurutschen. Jetzt ist es ja so, das ganze Netz ist noch sehr jung. Haben wir ja gerade auch festgestellt. Wir haben jetzt vielleicht gut 15 Jahre öffentliche Wahrnehmung und auch 15 Jahre, wo das Web eigentlich als solches funktioniert. Noch jünger sind eigentlich genau die Medien, die am Anfang, als das Internet aufkam, auch schon breitbandig zelebriert wurden mit Lalalala. Jeder ist ein Sender, jeder kann jetzt teilnehmen. Und wir werden jetzt alle irgendwie unsere eigene Zeitung und überhaupt und jeder ist ein Spiegel. Hat man jetzt schon berührt, das findet so in der Form nicht statt. Das war sicherlich auch eine sehr übermütige Feststellung. Trotzdem ist natürlich auch was dran. Du hast es ja auch selber gesagt, jetzt kann man sich besser informieren. Es gibt mehr Quellen. Diese Quellen müssen ja auch von irgendjemand bedient werden, weil wenn alle nur lesen würden, dann gäbe es halt keine Quellen mehr. Was hat sich jetzt bis dahin entwickelt? Es kam so um die Jahrtausendwende, kam die Technologie langsam an den Punkt, dass eben das mit diesem Selber publizieren auch wirklich Hand und Fuß hatte. Erste Leute haben irgendwie umfangreiche Webseiten gestartet und dann gab es so die nächsten Push mit Blogs. Weil Blogs machten es nun wirklich einfach und haben vor allem auch die Methodik der Benutzung einer Webseite das erste Mal halbwegs standardisiert und auf so einen Punkt gebracht, wo viele Leute was mit anfangen konnten. Manche nutzen es halt so ein bisschen für ihre Tagesbuchperspektive, andere eben, um einfach Nachrichten zu berichten oder sonst wie die Welt zu kommentieren. Jetzt kann man sagen, dass im Vergleich zu den anderen Medien im Netz, jetzt würde ich mal das Internet sozusagen nicht als Gesamtmedium, sondern eher so als Universal-Medientransport verwenden und mal schauen, was die kleinen Atome da drin so machen. Und die Blogs erscheinen mir ja schon mittlerweile einen gewissen Reifegrad erreicht zu haben. Und zwar sowohl was die Befüllung der Leute, die es schreiben, betrifft, als auch was das Lesen und Benutzen betrifft. Weil so wie heute alle wissen, was eine Tageszeitung ist und wie man die zu nehmen hat, muss sich das natürlich beim anderen Medium auch umsetzen. Man merkt, dass diese ganzen Missverständnisse, wenn die aufkommen, so Twitter ist neu, und dann glauben alle erst mal, das wäre das. Oder Facebook ist neu und dann denken alle, das wäre das. Fünf Jahre später stellen sie fest, na ja, das war es dann doch nicht so, nur so ein bisschen. Eigentlich ist es aber was anderes. Und bei Blogs war es sicherlich ähnlich. Da hatten wir Ewigkeiten, diese Tagebuch, nicht wahr? Die Leute schreiben ihr Tagebuch im Web-Debatte. Davon redet mittlerweile keiner mehr zurecht, wie ich finde. Und jetzt haben sich halt so Sachen herausgebildet, wie The Huffington Post zum Beispiel. Huffington Post in den USA. Kennst du denn noch andere? Wie siehst du konkret jetzt mal diesen Themenbereich Blogs, wie sich das entwickelt hat? Und kennst du da Blogmedien, die auch deinen Zuspruch finden?
Also ich habe einen sehr vollen Feedreader. Blogs sind tatsächlich eine sehr große Bereicherung, weil man sehr viel mehr Sichtweisen finden. Kann, dass man auch anders experimentieren kann beim Veröffentlichen. Also ich bin gleichzeitig Journalist und Blogger und genieße es sehr, dass ich diese zwei unterschiedlichen Kanäle zur Verfügung habe. Als Journalist bin ich sehr, sehr sachlich. Als Blogger kann ich auch ein bisschen auf die Pauke hauen. Die Blogs, die ich am meisten schätze, die sind schon jetzt wieder im Bereich Journalismus angekommen. Wenn ich zum Beispiel Netzpolitik sehe, die dann die Sicherheitslücken aufdecken, das habe ich dann für Heise auch öfters mal gemacht. Ich war sehr gespannt, welche Erfahrungen die damit machen. Wenn die Firmen anrufen, weil es war teilweise etwas frustrierend früher, als sich niemand um Datenschutz gekümmert hat, den Leuten zu vermitteln. Um Gottes Willen, ihr habt da eine riesen Sicherheitslücke. Dichtet das ab und da dann an die Leute ranzukommen, das hat teilweise drei Tage lang gedauert. Heute geht es mittlerweile in einem Tag, wenn man über die Pressestelle geht, um denen zu sagen, kümmert euch drum. Aber zurück zum Blogs, ich lese sehr oft Blogs von Journalisten, was an meinem Interessenbereich liegt. Es gibt wahrscheinlich sehr viele wunderschöne literarische Blogs. Es gibt wahrscheinlich sehr viel wunderbare Polemik im Blogs, aber da bin ich kein so großer Fan von, weil ich bin in gewisser Weise ein Informationspurist und von daher bin ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht der ideale Blogleser. Ich habe jetzt auch neu angefangen, beim Bildblog mich mit Medien zu beschäftigen, was mich weiter auf die Medienschiene bringt, wodurch ich mehr Blogs lese, die sich mit Medien beschäftigen, die auch wieder von Journalisten geschrieben werden. Von daher bin ich in so einer kleinen Echo-Chamber drin, sprich alles Leute, die sich mit den gleichen Themen beschäftigen, die die gleichen Interessen haben, die die gleichen Ausdrucksformen haben. Für mich, wenn man sich in einem gewissen Bereich informieren will, ist das eine sehr große Bereicherung. Es ist aber schwer über den Tellerrand hinauszusehen. Jetzt bin ich wieder etwas konfus gewesen. Was war nochmal die ursprüngliche Frage?
Eine Bewertung von Blogs. Hast du dich bei den Journalisten-Blogs... Was macht die Journalisten-Blogs wertvoller für dich, außer dass du jetzt auch Journalist bist und gucken willst, wie die anderen so arbeiten? Schreiben die einfach besser?
Sie haben ja Erfahrung mit Informationen umzugehen, Informationen prägnant zu vermitteln.
Was macht denn das aus? Ich will keinen kompletten Journalistendiskurs haben, aber vielleicht auch mal ausgehen von den gängigsten Fehlern, die du jetzt bei anderen siehst. Du sagst ja auch, du bist Informationspurist. Was vermisst du oder was ist zu viel an anderen Stellen, als dass ein Blog da Aufmerksamkeit abgibt?
Wenn ich zum Beispiel auf River manchmal betrachte, was nach oben gespült wird, wenn Artikel erst nach 5000 Zeichen zum Thema kommen, was sie überhaupt sagen wollen, dann ist das für mich sehr quälend. Aber das ist auch für viele andere, die auf dem sehr schnellen Internet- Informationskanal angewiesen sind, quälend.
Das heißt, wir hätten jetzt gerne diesen einleitenden Absatz, in dem schon mal die Kerninformation zusammengefasst wurde.
Zum Beispiel, zweiter Punkt, Umgang mit Informationen, die man bekommt. Wenn dann Spiegel-Stories oder Artikel von Publikumsmedien plötzlich als Skandal wahrgenommen werden und man weiß, wenn man ein bisschen sich mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt hat, ja, diese Nachricht ist nicht neu oder da fehlt der entscheidende Hintergrund, diese, man muss auch die andere Seite betrachten, beziehungsweise man muss das in den Kontext einordnen. Das machen Journalisten tendenziell besser. Natürlich gibt es auch viele schwarze Schafe bei Journalisten. Natürlich gibt es auch viele Versuchungen, nur die eine Seite zu beleuchten, weil man dadurch sehr viel mehr Applaus bekommt. Also dadurch, dass man, wenn man sich, du kennst das wahrscheinlich auch, wenn man sich die Abrufzahlen ansieht von manchen Blockbeiträgen, fasst man sich manchmal an den Kopf, erstens, warum wurde dieser Beitrag abgerufen, beziehungsweise über welche Google-Suchbegriffe kommen die Leute auf meine Artikel drauf? Und da fragt man sich wirklich, habe ich mit meinen Lesern tatsächlich irgendwie ein gemeinsames Level, ein gemeinsames Interesse? Man muss nur oft genug Sex irgendwo hinschreiben und es wird geklickt wie Sau. Und das ist manchmal sehr deprimierend. Und das verführt auch natürlich Blogger, die dann etwas schreiben und dann massig Reaktionen bekommen, ach, da hab ich was richtig gemacht und das mach ich jetzt weiter. Und diese Verführung, der muss man widerstehen. Also zum Beispiel bei der Russlandwahl gab es ein Video, was in einem russischen Wahllokal aufgenommen wurde und was massiv über alle Kanäle verbreitet wurde zu sehen, war ein Mensch, der in einem Wahllokal steht und was schreit. Und kaum jemand der Leute, die das tatsächlich gesehen haben und weiter verbreitet haben, konnte Russisch, bzw. niemand konnte Russisch, der das weiter verbreitet hat. Und nach, ich glaube, zwei Tagen hat sich rausgestellt, erstens, bei dieser Beschwerde ging es nicht um Wahlbetrug im engeren Sinne. Und zweitens, der Kontext war so was von fragwürdig, dass selbst wenn er was von Wahlbetrug geschrien hätte, man daraus überhaupt keinen Schluss hätte ziehen können. Es war halt, als ob man jemanden in der Kneipe belauscht und der sagt, ey, ich hab gehört totale Wahlfälschung und so weiter und so fort. Und in der Kneipe mit genug Alkohol im Spiel werden wir misstrauisch. Und dadurch, dass es halt in Blocks weitergetragen wurde, wurde das als authentisch wahrgenommen. Und wir haben einen Skandal, den die Mainstream-Medien nicht hatten. Natürlich wurden viele Skandale, die die Mainstream-Medien nicht hatten, auch über Blocks weitergetragen. Aber die meisten Skandale waren dann halt doch keine.
Das Verhältnis von den Journalisten zum Netz scheint ja auch recht gestört zu sein. In der Zeit gibt es ja da die rege Debatte über Qualität, über Finanzierung will ich jetzt erst gar nicht anfangen. Ich hatte es jetzt schon mal erwähnt, es gibt ja so Projekte wie die Huffington Post, die sich so ein bisschen als alternative Netzöffnung, also Medienöffentlichkeit von Anfang an verstanden hat und sich, wenn ich es richtig verfolgt habe, auch so, sagen wir mal, sich quasi im Blog-Style langsam zu so einem eigenen Medium hochgearbeitet hat. Mittlerweile relativ viel Aufmerksamkeit erhält. Ist das so ein Role-Model, für wohin die Reise hingehen kann? Weil die ja mittlerweile dann auch über eigene Spenden doch schon auch Geld aufkommen haben. Keine Ahnung, wie sich das bei denen zusammensetzt. Sicherlich auch über Werbung und ja auch Leute mittlerweile dafür bezahlt werden, dort zu schreiben.
Ich glaube, bei der Bezahlung waren sie relativ früh dabei, Leute zu bezahlen. Von daher, Huffington Post ist ein sehr amerikanisches Phänomen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das die Medienrevolution ist, beziehungsweise ob das so viel mit Vlogs zu tun hat. Weil Huffington Post ist natürlich das liberale Gegenmedium zu dem recht konservativen Talkradio in den USA. Huffington Post ist quasi der konzentrierte liberal media bias. Es wird nur aus einem Standpunkt berichtet. Es kommen nur Leute zu Wort, die einer gewissen politischen Denkrichtung entsprechen. Und was teilweise bei der New York Times angeprangert wird von der breiten Öffentlichkeit nach dem Motto, ihr berichtet nur für die liberale Intellektuelle Elite. Das ist bei der Huffington Post natürlich sehr viel konzentrierter der Fall.
Ist das aber nicht auch typisch für ein Internet-basiertes Medium, dass es einfach sehr viel mehr Gruppierungen um ein bestimmtes Kernthema gibt?
Ja, das ist natürlich sehr viel mehr im Internet so. Die Frage ist, ist es tatsächlich Crowdsourcing oder hätte Huffington Post auch mit einer anderen Technik ohne quasi die Publikumsbeteiligung die Verbreitung gefunden? Hätte jetzt quasi, wäre über Kabelkanäle in den USA das Internet verbreitet worden, mehr so ein AOL-Modell, dann wäre Huffington Post auch möglich gewesen.
Na gut, da rollen wir es noch mal anders aus. Noch mal so zurück zu den Blogs als solchen, auch jetzt vielleicht von denen, die jetzt nicht von Journalisten geschrieben sind. Also es gibt ja genug Blogs, du hast ja schon Netzpolitik erwähnt, das ist ja mittlerweile das meistgelesenste Blog, wenn man jetzt den automatisch generierten Statistiken glauben mag, hat definitiv eine gewisse Öffentlichkeit für sich erarbeitet. Es gibt ein paar andere Blogs, bei denen es ähnlich geht, die allerdings alle sehr unterschiedlich sind und viele sind aber auch sehr privater Natur. Also es sind auch Dinge sehr populär, die jetzt gar nicht so sehr versuchen, so journalistisch aufzutreten oder besonders anbeißt zu sein, sondern tatsächlich hat eben auch so dieser persönliche Blickwinkel ja schon auch eine gewisse Popularität und sicherlich damit auch eine bestimmte Glaubwürdigkeit. Also sind das für dich dann auch noch ernstzunehmende Quellen, die du irgendwie verfolgst? Also welches Regulativ stellen die da?
Wenn sie sehr persönlich sind, sind sie in der Regel für die journalistische Arbeit einfach selten zu gebrauchen, weil wenn jemand sagt, ich war in so einem tollen Konzert und kann darüber prima schreiben, mag das für mich als Kontumenten sehr interessant sein. Aber in meinem speziellen Bereich, wo ich journalistisch tätig bin, ist das für mich dann kaum zu gebrauchen. Ich kann es trotzdem dann gerne lesen, beziehungsweise ich kann es dann weiter verbreiten, ach, da habe ich so eine tolle Konzertkritik gesehen. Aber für die journalistische Arbeit sind die meisten Blogs ein Grundrauschen. Es sind so viele Informationen unterwegs. Ich höre auch immer wieder überraschende Zahlen, dass es 500.000 Blogs in Deutschland geben soll, dass es Millionen in Frankreich, USA geben soll. Die haben natürlich alle einen sehr kleinen Verbreitungsraum. Und wenn man journalistisch Blogs nutzen will, sucht man sich drei, vier, zehn, zwanzig aus, die für einen interessant sind. Das Schöne ist ja, dass jeder Blogger dann auch wieder seine drei, vier, zehn, zwanzig Blogs hat, aus denen er Informationen generiert, die er dann auch wieder weiter verbreitet. So entsteht dann auch eine stille Post, die manchmal langsamer, manchmal schneller einen dann auch wieder zu den Informationen führt, wo man sie ursprünglich nicht gesucht hätte. Und das ist quasi das Gegenregulativ zu Google. Dass ich Informationen gezielt suche, bei Google mit bestimmten Suchworten, da bin ich auch sehr darauf angewiesen, dass die Leute die richtigen Worte benutzen, dass sie in der richtigen Sprache schreiben, dass Google die richtig einsortiert. Wenn ich aber die eher persönliche Wahrnehmung eines Menschen im Blog abbilde, habe ich dadurch die Gegenbewegung. Der persönliche Blogger ist dann auch wieder ein Gatekeeper. Er verbreitet Informationen, die man sonst übersehen hätte.
Das heißt, Blogs haben vor allem dadurch einen Wert, dass sie eben vernetzt sind, dass sie auf Quellen verweisen. Das heißt, das Verlinken ist die eigentliche Kernqualität.
Bei Qualität wäre ich jetzt vorsichtig.
Qualität für die Recherche meine ich jetzt.
Ja, anderer Aspekt ist auch, dass die Leute merken, wie man mit Informationen umgeht. Negativ Beispiel, wenn man eine Abmahnung kassiert, dann bekommt man plötzlich einen ganz anderen, einen sehr intensiven Lehrgang in Persönlichkeits- und Markenrechten. Beziehungsweise, wenn jede Blog-Installation hat, primär mal die Kommentare offen. Und dann merken viele Leute, wie man an sich miteinander umgehen sollte, beziehungsweise welche Reaktionen man nicht gerne hat. Weil fast jeder, der ins Internet kommt und dann sein erstes eigenes Ding hat, der fängt stolz an seine URL überall hin zu posten. Wenn er hingegen dann plötzlich selber in seinem Blog lauter Kommentare hat, toller Beitrag, guck mal mein Blog an, dann wird er bald auch davon genervt sein. Sprich, man lernt auch die andere Seite kennen. Es entsteht so, um wieder zurück zum Thema zu kommen der Sendung, Medienkompetenz. Dadurch, dass ich in einer Rolle als Sender bin, entdecke ich das Medium von der anderen Seite. Und wie man mit Reaktionen umgeht, wie Leute auch Verbesserungsvorschläge machen, wie ich diese Verbesserungsvorschläge aufgreife, auch die sehr wertvollen Aspekte, dass Leute, sobald man publiziert, einen anmelden und sagen, hey, ich habe etwas Tolles gefunden, was auch zum Thema passt. Das sind alles sehr wertvolle Lektionen, die Medienkompetenz vermitteln.
Also learning by doing and trial and error. Im Prinzip möchtest du schon, dass irgendwie alles zumindest mal probieren, aber dann eben auch daraus lernen, wenn sie dann anfangen zu scheitern.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass natürlich manche das Falsche lernen. Es gibt Communities, die kippen um. Es gibt Blogs, die kippen um. Die werden immer polemischer, die werden immer abgekapselter. Ein sehr großer Beispiel ist dann dieses berühmte Politically Incorrect, wo sich eine sehr harte Szene gewildert hat, die sich immer weiter selbst bestätigt in ihrem Weltbild.
Das ist ein amerikanisches Blog?
Nein, das ist ein deutsches Blog, die sich als Islam kritisch bezeichnen und sehr in die rechte Ecke abgetriftet sind, sodass man, ich würde sie an sich als negative Seite von Medienkompetenz sehen.
Ach, PI New, alles klar, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Die auch hier in Köln angesiedelt waren früher und auch mal. Früher waren dort kleine Aufkleber an Ampeln, die dafür geworben haben. Mittlerweile sind diese kleinen Aufkleber immer noch da und aber teilweise schon eindeutig ausländerfeindlich, rechtsradikal, nationalsozialistisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob die gleichen Leute dahinter stecken, aber durch die Möglichkeiten des Internets bestehen natürlich auch die Möglichkeiten der Radikalisierung. Sich nur noch mit gewissen Leuten abzugeben.
Da gibt es ja auch so eine sehr breite Bewegung im Netz von, na ja, also jetzt hier auch bei PoliticalInnen korrekt, gleich die erste Feststellung im Untertitel ist gegen den Mainstream. Mainstream scheint sich in bestimmten Bereichen auch schon so richtig als Schimpfwort fest etabliert zu haben. Da gibt es ja dann so eine ganze Batterie von verschwörungsorientierten Seiten. Ich habe so immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck, seit 9-11 ging das erst so richtig los. So ein Ereignis, bei dem man wirklich seine Zweifel hat. Das gab es natürlich alles vorher, aber dann vor allem eben auch im Netz. Also wo diese ganze Attacke anfing mit Aufklärungsvideos, wie es wirklich war. Und jetzt haben wir ja schon eine ganze Rabatte von Impfgegnern, ja gerade so im medizinischen Bereich, was nicht alles irgendwie nicht stimmt. Dann jetzt gerade ganz wild in der Debatte halt so die Klimaskeptiker-Fraktion. Also ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass die einen jetzt recht haben oder nicht recht haben, aber ganz offensichtlich entbrennt da im Netz ein Kampf, wo es sehr viele Medien gibt, die dann sehr doch wirklich sich extrem in diesem, wie das hier so schön steht, in diesem gegen den Mainstream-Ding verfangen, was dann auch schon so religiöse Charakterzüge manchmal kriegt. Kennst du da noch ein paar Beispiele und wie nimmst du das wahr?
Wenn ich ein bisschen ausholen darf, also einer meiner ersten journalistischen Erfahrungen war, bzw. nicht die allererste, aber während der Journalistenschule war ich im Praktikum bei der Stuttgarter Zeitung in der Online-Redaktion, damals ganz, ganz neu. Und da wurde die Internetseite erstmals aufgebaut. Und ich saß dann eine Woche lang quasi an einem Arbeitsplatz mit drei Bildschirmen, wo dann auf zwei Bildschirmen die Nachrichtenagenturen vorbeitickerten. Täglich 1500 Meldungen, die ich tatsächlich durchging und daraus dann 10 bis 12 Meldungen für die Zeitung Stuttgarter Nachrichten, für die Nachrichtenticker extrahiert habe. Das war eine sehr lehrreiche Lektion, einfach zu sehen, wie sich Nachrichten entwickeln. Quasi, es gibt bei dem Unfall vier Tote. Das schreibt die eine Agentur, die nächste spricht von sechs Toten. Und zwei Stunden später, es gab überhaupt keine Tote. Die Informationen, die man schnell bekommt, sind teilweise sehr unsicher. Man muss sich immer Gedanken machen, woher wissen die Leute das? Wie ist diese Information überhaupt zustande gekommen? Das ist eine der Kernfragen der Medienkompetenz, die viel zu selten gestellt wird. Jetzt komme ich zu den Verschwörungstheorien. Da ist nämlich dieses gleiche Phänomen. Es gab diesen Film, wo über eine Stunde diese neuen L-Verschwörungstheorien aneinandergereiht wurden. Der Film wurde auch selbst von Leuten, die nicht so abgetriftet sind im Verschwörungsbereich als journalistisch wertvoll weiterverbreitet, weil er sich auf offizielle Quellen berufen hat, weil er gesagt hat, ja, wir haben das ausprobiert und so weiter. Das geht überhaupt nicht. Im Netz hat sich dann auch eine kleine Gegenbewegung entwickelt, die tatsächlich die Fakten überprüft hat. Und dann hat sich herausgestellt, ja, es gab diese Meldung der AP zu diesem Zeitpunkt, aber das war halt einer dieser vorläufigen Reporter, die in der Panik des Augenblicks verfasst wurde und die nicht gestimmt haben. Und dadurch, dass während der Attacke auf das World Trade Center sind ja auch Internetleitungen beschädigt worden, sind viele Medien in Notbetrieb gegangen, weil ihre Kommunikationskanäle auch beschädigt wurden. Dadurch wurden auch viele Gerüchte schnell verbreitet, weil jeder was lesen wollte.
Du weißt so, wie hier das CNN oder BBC berichtet, das Haus ist eingestürzt, im Hintergrund ein sogenanntes Live-Bild, wo das Haus dann noch zu sehen war, sowas.
Genau. Und daraus kann man aus diesen Fehlinformationen alternative Erklärungsmodelle stricken, die auf den ersten Blick logisch erscheinen. Wenn man dann aber den Kontext sieht, ja, wie ist das damals entstanden, und dann noch mal nachrecherchiert, ja, kann man tatsächlich mit dem Handy im Flugzeug telefonieren, dann bricht das Ganze wieder zusammen. Also, man muss sich die Frage stellen, wo kommen Informationen her, was für ein Interesse haben Leute, das zu verbreiten. Eines der großen Schwachpunkte der neuen L-Verschwörungstheorien ist, was hätte Bush für ein Interesse daran gehabt, das World Trade Center in die Luft zu jagen. Weil mit Motiven und so weiter kann man sehr viel spekulieren, aber richtig überzeugend wird das dann nie. Jetzt müsste ich noch mal auf die Frage zurückkommen.
Die Frage ist natürlich auch, wie geht man jetzt mit diesen Kanälen um? In zunehmendem Maße bilden sich Instanzen heraus, die alle die Wahrheit für sich gepachtet haben. Das, was man dem Mainstream in Anführungsstrichen ja auch immer unterstellt. Neben dem Mainstream hat man noch so einen Nicht-Mainstream, der eigentlich genauso dogmatisch, wenn nicht noch dogmatischer herkommt. Manchmal bei bestimmten Themen, zumindest der Eindruck, den das auf mich macht. Wie kann man jetzt aussortieren? Dann nehmen wir mal so ein richtig komplexes Thema, diese aktuelle Klimadebatte. Wird die Erde jetzt wärmer oder nicht? Ich habe dann auch in meinem Umfeld irgendwie solche und solche. Da gibt es irgendwie die überzeugten Langzeitumweltaktivisten. Für die ist das irgendwie einfach mal gesetzt, das Thema, weil das war schon immer so und jetzt haben wir was dagegen zu tun. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es dann eben die Leute, die sich dann eben auch im Netz aus Quellen unterrichten lassen, die dann eben so ihre Anfangskepsis untermauern und dann da eben hinterhergraben und sehen, oh, da gibt es ja noch sehr viel mehr Informationen, die werden nicht berichtet, da, ja, was weiß ich, weiß der Geier, wie viel Millionen Elgor mit Umweltschutz verdienen möchte und so weiter. So, und jetzt steht man da so als Dritter daneben und weiß schon gar nicht mehr, wie soll man das jetzt überprüfen? Also was sagt mir jetzt sozusagen die Lehre der Medienkompetenz, dieser kleinen, aber feinen neuen Wissenschaftsdisziplin, wie ich jetzt diese Gegenwelten gegeneinander abwerden soll?
Wie die Medienkompetenzwissenschaftler dazu stehen, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber zwei verschiedene Aspekte. Wenn eine Mädel ankommt, die dir einen Job anbietet, hast du gelernt, das ist Spam. Beziehungsweise du hast gelernt mit gewissen... Deswegen hab ich immer noch keinen. Ja, das könnte... Nee, ist mir noch nicht passiert, aber das ist von manchen Leuten passiert, dass ernst gemeinte Jobangebote tatsächlich zuerst als Spam abgehakt wurden. Aber man hat gelernt, auf gewisse Wortkombinationen zu reagieren und das dann als Blödsinn abzuhandeln. Und wenn irgendwas von Chialis in einem Mail betreff steht, ob da eine Eins drin ist oder so, dann lösche ich das ungesehen weg mit einem ganz kleinen Risiko, dass ich tatsächlich eine wertvolle Information weglösche. Wir müssen lernen, damit umzugehen. In meinem Berufsumfeld ist es so, wenn ich in einer Pressemitteilung lese, Dings, Dings, Dings ist eines der führenden Unternehmen in so und so. Und da steht nichts weiter, um diesen Anspruch zu belegen. Dann ist es in der Regel so, dass das kein führendes Unternehmen ist, sondern dass es einfach eine kleine Klitsche ist von einem Einpersonenhaushalt, der meint, er müsste mal auf die Pauke hauen und sich als groß darstellen, um ernst genommen zu werden. Wenn man sich ein bisschen mit gewissen Szenen beschäftigt, lernt man gewisse Muster zu erkennen und Sachen einzuordnen. Das richtig in den Kontext setzen kann man aber nur, wenn man sich wirklich kundig macht. Weil in dieser ganzen Breite des Internets, wenn ich mir jetzt nicht nur meinen ganz engen Twitter-Followerkreis anziehe, sondern tatsächlich das ganze Twitter nehme, dann habe ich eher eine Möglichkeit, eine falsche Information zu bekommen, als eine richtige Information zu bekommen. Eine Möglichkeit ist Vertrauen. Vertrauensketten, ja, ich habe einen Naturwissenschaftler als Freund, der sich damit auskennt, der diese Quelle gelesen hat und sie weiter empfiehlt. Das ist eine Möglichkeit zu recherchieren. Und natürlich gibt es dann wieder auch die Massenmedien, die teilweise noch manchmal besser, manchmal schlechter den Job machen, diesen generellen Fragen nachzugehen.
Teilweise, sagst du. Ich bin jetzt nicht besonders vertrauenswürdig. Und wenn ich jetzt keine Wissenschaftler in meiner Umgebung habe, was mache ich dann halt? Da geht eigentlich meine Frage hin. Kannst du irgendwelche Mechanismen benennen, denen man vielleicht folgen sollte, oder die man sich ein bisschen zur Marschroute macht, auch wenn man jetzt eben diese Freunde nicht hat? Und ich meine, jetzt ein etabliertes Massenmedium, was teilweise manchmal vielleicht noch ordentlich berichtet, kann ja jetzt für mich keine Grundlage sein, so eine Quelle zu bewerten.
Es gibt da viele Möglichkeiten. Ein nicht so unterschätzender Faktor sind Äußerlichkeiten. Es mag altmodisch klingen, aber Rechtstreibung ist tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit, relativ verlässliche Informationen tendenziell vorzufildern. Wenn jemand einfach nur Kleinschreibung, ohne Rechtsschreibung, ohne Punkt und Komma etwas absondert, dann ist meine persönliche Erfahrung, dass auch die Informationen, die er vermitteln will, nicht ganz so zuverlässig sind. Zweitens, einen Klick weitergehen. Gucken, was hat der Mensch vorher dazu geschrieben? Gucken, woher hat er die Informationen? Nachgucken, welche Qualifikation hat er? Reimmt er sich das zu Hause zusammen? Hat er irgendeinen Kroll gegen Liberale und ist deswegen gegen die Erderwärmung? Oder hat er Physik studiert bzw. hat er eine statistische Analyse gemacht und hat deswegen konkrete Fehler gefunden? Wie eben angesprochen, woher bezieht er die Information? Es ist oft nicht auf den ersten Blick erkennbar, wie eine Information weiterverbreitet wurde. Da hilft es manchmal auch bei Google nach bestimmten Wortkombinationen zu suchen, um zu sehen, ach, das hat er dort abgeschrieben. Und diese Quelle ist das und diese Quelle ist für mich nicht glaubwürdig, weil sie eher einen ideologischen Standpunkt hat, als ich tatsächlich um wissenschaftliche Dinge zu kümmern. Wirklich ermitteln kann man das kaum. Man kann immer weiter recherchieren und irgendwann muss man sagen Schluss. Du wirst für dich persönlich nicht das Problem lösen der Erderwärmung, sondern du kannst dir nur deine persönliche Meinung bilden. Und dazu musst du dir ein gewisses Handwerkzeug aufbauen, wenn du dich nicht auf kurzer Informationsschnipsel verlassen willst, musst du ständig Informationen aufnehmen, die dich einfach nicht interessieren.
Ja, kostet natürlich alles eine Menge Zeit und ist irgendwie ein Aufwand, den dann viele Leute natürlich in der Regel nicht bereit sind zu machen. Ich freu mich gerade, ob man diese Vertrauensketten, die man ja quasi rauslesen möchte, ob es da irgendeine Chance gibt, das zu automatisieren, zu mechanisieren. Kennst du Strukturen im Netz, die so eine Bewertung, so eine Quellenbewertung unterstützen für einen?
Unterstützen? Ja, also Google ist natürlich das ultimative Medium, um Recherchen zu erweitern bzw. an weitere Informationen zu kommen. Auch die erweiterten Google-Optionen, zum Beispiel herauszufinden, welche Links führen zu einem Beitrag, was viele Menschen nicht machen, was mir aber sehr oft den entscheidenden Vorsprung bringt. Ja, da hat jemand diesem Blogbeitrag widersprochen, allerdings wurde seinen Dreck weggelöscht. Und da ist dann die entscheidende Information, die den Kontext zu dem Blogbeitrag bietet. Pauschal hilft einfach nur Neugier. Man muss gucken, wie man mit dem Medium umgehen kann. Mehr als den ersten Klick, auch den zweiten Klick, den dritten Klick. Und wenn man zum 100. Klick übergeht, ist man schon Fachmann. Wo man die Grenze setzt, ist eine persönliche Frage. Und da du persönlich die Erderwärmung nicht ändern kannst, würde dich das weniger interessieren. Dich wird aber interessieren, wo kriege ich einen Kühltrank her, wo ich eine Förderung früher her bekomme. Und wenn du diesen Teil erfüllt hast, dann hast du für dich persönlich schon eine wertvolle Information gefunden.
Ein Problem, was du ja so beklagst, ist ja, dass man sich da selber eigentlich in dieser Skandalschreierei eigentlich zum Instrument macht. Da kommt dann irgendwie so die Information rein, dann habe ich die jetzt einfach mal so geglaubt, weil meiner Meinung nach ist die Vertrauenskette ausreichend hergestellt, weil das ist ja mein Freund und der sagt ja auch sonst immer so viele kluge Sachen und dann muss das ja jetzt auch einfach mal stimmen und dann wird das halt einfach retweetet. Ja, ich reiche einfach nur seine Aussage, mehr oder weniger ungefiltert, vielleicht noch ein bisschen begleitkommentiert, aber in der Regel halt auch nicht mal das, wird halt einfach weitergetragen und erhält natürlich dadurch mehr Bedeutung. Ist dem überhaupt ein, gut, das muss ja jetzt auch nichts Schlechtes sein und es sind ja auch sicherlich viele richtige und wichtige Informationen so auch nach oben gespült worden. Aber was würdest du denn für ein Eigenkommunikationsverhalten begrüßen, was die Problematik der Weiterreichung von besonders unwahren Geschichten irgendwie vermeidet, ohne dass man jetzt jedes Mal nach recherchiert?
Hören anschalten. Also gerade in der Wikipedia-Debatte in den letzten Wochen war ich sehr, sehr deprimiert, wie viele Falschinformationen verbreitet wurden. Auch Leute, die ich schätze, ich habe also einen sehr kleinen Twitter-Kreis von Leuten, die ich lese, von denen ich eine große Medienkompetenz zutraue, die ich es einfach nicht gemacht habe. Ich habe zum Beispiel den AK Zensur von Anfang an begleitet und dann lese ich plötzlich auf Twitter, der Artikel in Wikipedia zu AK Zensur wurde gelöscht. Ich wusste nicht, dass es einen Artikel zu AK Zensur gab. Ich konnte aber auch nicht ausschließen, dass es kurzfristig einen gab und der gelöscht wurde. Und die Anstrengung, die es mich gekostet hat, war, herauszufinden, ob das tatsächlich stimmt war. Ich habe bei Google die Wikipedia-Adresse eingegeben und habe sofort gesehen, da war kein Artikel. Es war einfach nur ein Satz, siehe Meinungsseite oder so. Jemand hat Diskussionsseite mit Artikelseite verwechselt. Und dieser Nicht-Artikel wurde gelöscht und es wurde weiterverbreitet, ja, die Wikipedia hat wieder einen sehr wertvollen Artikel gelöscht, was einfach nicht gestimmt hat. Und es ist sehr deprimierend manchmal zu sehen, wie viele dieser Falschinformationen unwidersprochen weiterverbreitet wurden, auch von Leuten, für die es an sich völlig normal wäre, auch mal in Google-Cache nachzusehen bzw. die so viele Wikipedianer kennen, dass die einfach mal nachgucken könnten, innerhalb von 30 Sekunden. Diese Cache-Research hat mich 15 Sekunden gekostet. Dies hätte sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel mehr gekostet. Du wärst wahrscheinlich nicht sofort auf die Idee gekommen, jetzt mal in Google-Cache nachzugucken. Aber du persönlich kennst so viele Wikipedianer, die es für dich hätten nachgucken können, die es dir hätten erklären können. Diese Mühe, diese geringe Mühe.
Da habe ich jetzt wieder so ein Privileg meines bekannten Kreises. Aber das geht ja eben für viele Leute nicht. Mittlerweile gibt es einen Artikel über den Arbeitskreis. War dann wahrscheinlich auch die Folge davon. Vielleicht ist das sozusagen die Methode, sich einen Artikel zu verschaffen in der Wikipedia. Dass man beklagt, man sei gelöscht worden, wo man noch nie existiert hatte.
Ja, das ist eine sehr verbreitete Methode. Es kommen jeden Monat Pressemitteilungen von aufgebrachten Jungunternehmern raus, dass sie eine Wikipedia gelöscht wurden. Und sie machen dann das große Gegenprojekt. Und gerade gestern kam wieder die nächste Erklärung. Ja, wir machen das große Gegenprojekt zur Wikipedia. Bei uns kann man auch Webseiten anmelden. Und hier gibt es keine Zensur. Und dann habe ich mal wieder den Klick weiter gemacht. Die gleiche Firma hat vor sechs Monaten schon ein Gegenprojekt zur Wikipedia angekündigt, das heute nicht mehr erreichbar ist. Und dann noch einen Klick weiter gemacht. Die Firma, die angeblich eine der führenden Firmen bei CEO, also Search Engine Optimizing ist, die ist unbekannt in dem Markt. Von daher ein bisschen Mühe machen beim Verbreiten, beim Retweeting. Ein bisschen das Vertrauen hinterfragen, das man in manche Quellen hat, das würde ich mir manchmal wünschen.
Jetzt hast du ja die Wikipedia eigentlich vom Start weg begleitet. Also ich kann mich erinnern, als ich mich damit beschäftigt habe, hast du schon heiße Artikel darüber geschrieben. Ich will jetzt nicht diese ganze Relevanzdebatte hier aufkochen, weil das ist nochmal so ein anderes Ding. Aber natürlich spielt sowohl jetzt im Umgang mit dem Projekt als auch eben, wenn man sich selbst darin beschäftigt, diese Medienkompetenz natürlich auch eine gewisse Rolle. Auch so diese Fragestellung, vielleicht jetzt nicht so sehr unter dem Aspekt Recherche, sondern eben auch so dieses Feststellen, was hat denn jetzt hier stattgefunden? Offensichtlich gibt es ja ein Problem. Also kann nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit um diese ganze Geschichte geben, ohne dass da nicht Probleme vorherrschen. Wie hast du das wahrgenommen und woran hakt es?
Natürlich gibt es Probleme mit Wikipedia. Teilweise gibt es auch Probleme einfach nur in der Wahrnehmung. Wikipedia wurde von Anfang an plötzlich in die demokratische Ecke gestürmt. Hey, das ist ein demokratisches Objekt, das war es nie. Jeder, der Internet-Communities kennt, weiß, mit Demokratie ist relativ wenig zu gewinnen. Meist sind es Administratoren, die sich darum kümmern, dass ein Beitrag in ein Trollforum verschoben wird. Es sind relativ unverbindliche Regeln, die man vorgeben kann, weil irgendwie sämtliche Eventualitäten vorher in einem Regelwerk unterzubekommen, dass auch irgendwie alltagstauglich ist. Das ist ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit. Es ist auch in dieser ganzen Wikipedia-Debatte sind auch wieder diese Missverständnisse der Wissensvermittlung aufeinandergeprallt. Beziehungsweise es gibt das Missverständnis, dass Wissen einfach nur irgendwo mal aufgeschrieben werden muss und dann ist es in der Welt. Die Wahrheit ist, Wissen ist Arbeit. Wissen ist viel Arbeit. Wissen muss gepflegt werden. Und diese Notwendigkeit wird oft nicht gesehen. Und daraus ergeben sich dann viele Probleme. Wie als Wikipedia konkret mit dem Problem umgeht, das ist verlässliche Quellen zu finden, ist jetzt die Quadratur des Kreises. Früher, Brockhaus hatte eine einfache Methode. Die haben genommen, was in der Unibibliothek stand und von den Koryphäen des Fachs zitiert wurde. Es gibt Zitatsdatenbanken, aus denen sich Wissenschaftler bedienen können. Dieser ganze verlässliche, eingespielte Kreis, der wird jetzt aufgebrochen.
Und die Wikipedia hat alles als relevant angesehen, was in Brockhaus stand, und jetzt wird keiner mehr publiziert?
Die Wikipedia ist sehr früh darauf auf diesen Schuh gekommen. Wir gucken an, wie viele Google-Treffer es zu einem Thema gibt. Und wir wissen, wie leicht man Google-Treffer manipulieren kann. Quasi sie sind erst von den klassischen Enzyklopedien als die Leute, die absolut Flaptik mit Quellen umgehen, verschrien worden. Fehlinformationen wurden skandalisiert. Nach dem Motto, alle vertrauen Wikipedia. Und wenn dann drin steht, dass ein US-Journalist was mit dem JFK-Mord zu tun hatte, ist das eine sehr schwere Verletzung des Ganzen. Und jetzt kommt die andere Seite und sagt, ihr seid nicht frei genug. Ihr müsst alles frei geben, egal ob es stimmt oder nicht. Wie es jetzt konkret in der Wikipedia läuft, da gibt es natürlich viele Probleme, viel Ego. Die Wikipedia, Jimmy Wales hat das am Anfang ganz unterschätzt, der meinte auch, Wikipedia, um Gottes Willen, das soll doch keine Community werden. Deswegen existieren auch kaum Community-Features. Jetzt soll es nur um Wissen gehen. Und es wurde doch zum Lebensraum. Nur dadurch, dass es zum Lebensraum wurde, wurde Wikipedia so ein Erfolg. Weil, wenn man sich die Zahlen ansieht, die große Anzahl von Wikipedia-Artikeln kommt von ganz wenigen Leuten. Es ist wie in jeder Internet-Community, einige wenige machen den Lüfen-Anteil der Arbeit. Und wenn man sich ansieht, wie oft Falschinformationen gezielt gepostet werden, wie oft quasi Flaming-Wars in die Wikipedia getragen werden und wie schwer es ist, die rauszusortieren. Jeder, der mal mit einem Troll zu tun hatte, wusste, die haben ein halbes Jahr nichts anderes zu tun, als dein Leben schwer zu machen. Und Wikipedia hat einige sehr komische Mechanismen gefunden, damit fertig zu werden, einfach Leute zu frustrieren. Leute, die man einfach loswerden will, die kann man mit der 25. Regel von §4 der 15. Seite, die niemand findet, zurechtweisen und dann eine Sperrung beantragen und so weiter und so fort. Und damit frustriert man gleichzeitig aber auch die Leute, die konstruktiv arbeiten wollen. Das Lustige ist aber auch, dass sich jetzt quasi in der gleichen Diskussion Leute von beiden Lagern, die sich absolut nicht leiden können, die eigentlich auch die absolut gegensätzlichen Standpunkte vertreten, gleichzeitig auf die Wikipedia einhauen. Und wenn man sie dann fragt, was ihre Alternative ist, dann...
Welche beiden Seiten meinst du denn jetzt, die sich eigentlich nicht vertragen?
Teilweise die Leute, die sehr darauf vertrauen, dass die Offenheit schon zu einem wertvollen Ergebnis, zum Wissen führt. Und teilweise die Leute, die eher skeptischer sind. Aber auch Leute, die Homöopathie vertreten und Leute, die Homöopathie für absolute Bauernfängerei halten. Dadurch, dass Wikipedia überall einen Mittelweg finden muss, verkratzt sie sich mit beiden Extremen. Und wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, was da für Alternativen aufgezeigt werden, die dann von den Leuten der absoluten Freiheit angebracht werden, die laufen letztlich aber, wenn man zwei Sätze weiterdenkt oder weiterliest, laufen diese Vorschläge darauf hinaus, dass Wikipedia viel geschlossener werden muss. Dass man diese ganzen Diskussionen abwirken soll, weil niemand möchte diese 50 Kilobyte Diskussion lesen. Deswegen wird Wikipedia gerade auf einem Niveau attackiert, wo nur die Polemik der Spindelmittel der verschiedenen Lager ist. Wo dann teilweise auch Wahnseiten von absoluten Leuten, also Charlatane, die in der Wikipedia abgewiesen wurden, sehr oft eine Wikipedia-Wahnseite aufmachen und sagen, das sind alles Nazis, das sind alles Kommunisten, das sind die großen Zensoren und diese werden jetzt als Kronzeugen verwendet. Aber wenn man jetzt sein Gegenprojekt aufmachen würde, würde man diesen Menschen da nichts haben wollen. Und zwei Probleme existieren. Wir wissen noch viel zu wenig, was wissen, wie viel Arbeitwissen ist. Und das zweite Problem ist, wir kriegen die Egos nicht raus.
Aber hat das nicht vielleicht auch ein bisschen damit zu tun, dass einfach zu viel Wert darauf gelegt wird auf die Wikipedia? Dass es einfach in der kurzen Zeit jetzt zu große Bedeutung erlangt hat? Jetzt ist irgendwie der Brockhaus, wird nicht mehr publiziert. Jetzt ist das irgendwie so auf einmal das Weltwissen. Und das war ja natürlich auch gerade bei den Nerds, sind wir wieder bei den Nerds, von Anfang an so ein bisschen der Traum. Naja, das ist ja der Anhalter, den wir schon immer haben wollten, per Analysie die Galaxis, unser universelles Büchlein, wo irgendwie coole Sachen drinstehen. Auch in dem Kontext gab es ja interessante Debatten, ob denn das jetzt eigentlich nicht dann doch vielleicht die Encyclopedia Galactica ist, die dann irgendwann mal vom Anhalter ersetzt wurde, weil der Anhalter ja von sehr viel mehr Leuten irgendwie geschrieben wird und so weiter und ja überhaupt viel lebendiger und moderner war. Andererseits, habe ich es so noch nicht gelesen, erinnere ich mich aber auch an die Passage, wo der Artikel, den Fort Prefect mal über die Erde geschrieben hat, der sehr ausführlich war und über New York und über die Leute, die man liebt und wo man irgendwie guten Hamburger kriegt und so weiter, und dann irgendwann von der Redaktion gekürzt wurde auf Mostly Harmless. Größtenteils harmlos. Das hätte dann eigentlich auch schon alles gesagt über die Erde. Das ist natürlich dann nochmal ein toller Witz innerhalb dieses Buches, aber eben auch schön sagt, wie das eben so ist mit diesen Perspektiven. Also man kann natürlich über alles ausführlich schreiben, aber irgendjemand muss oder zumindest bestimmt am Ende immer, irgendjemand was eigentlich das relevante ist. Ist das überhaupt ein lösbarer Konflikt?
Nein.
Brauchen wir mehrere Wikipedias?
Ja, lass mich nochmal ein bisschen ausholen. Die Parallelen zum Anhalter der Galaxis sind noch viel schöner. Es gibt einen Kapitel, wo beschrieben wird, dass der Anhalter selbst gar nicht mehr von den Angestellten geschrieben wird, die sich einfach nur eine tolle Zeit machen, sondern dass dann Leser in die Redaktionsräume kommen und einfach tun, was getan werden muss. Zweiter Gag war auch, dass der große Plapperkäfer von Traal, dass ein Artikel in diesem Anhalter war, der große Plapperkäfer von Traal macht Reisenden gerne ein schmackhaftes Menü. Die Wahrheit war, er macht Ausreisenden ein schmackhaftes Menü, was natürlich dann für den Anhalter eine sehr blöde Information ist. Das ist auch eine Sache, die etwas untergeht in der Diskussion gerade. Falschinformationen können schaden. Wir erinnern uns vielleicht ein paar Jahre zurück. Da hatte der CCC das erste große Problem mit der Wikipedia als Wikipedia drauf bestand, den Realnamen des Hakkas Thron zu nennen, wo dann darauf appelliert wurde... Persönlichkeitsrechte. Nicht nur Persönlichkeitsrechte, sondern eher auf Anstand wurde argumentiert. Die Persönlichkeitsrechte wurden später dann im Prozess auf sehr komische Weise ins Fels gebracht. Aber das ist die andere Seite der Offenheit. Falsche Informationen in Wikipedia können Schaden bringen, erstens für den Betroffenen. Also in dem Fall auch richtige Informationen.
Der Name war ja nicht falsch, sondern es wurde ja nur darüber debattiert, ob er denn überhaupt erwähnt werden sollte oder nicht.
Ja, gestern habe ich auf cnn.com gelesen, dass ein Urteil einer Frau, wo gesagt wurde, nach einem Jahr ist ihre Gerichtsakte bzw. ihr Vorstrafenregister gelöscht. Es wird immer noch in einem Jahr auf cnn.com stehen mit ihrem Bild. Dieses Problem hatte auch Wikipedia. Es gibt 300.000 Personenartikel knapp auf Wikipedia. Ich bin sehr froh, dass es keinem Artikel zu mir gibt, weil es immer wieder Leute gibt. Gibt es einen Artikel über dich? Ich glaube, ja. Es gab wahrscheinlich auch mal Leute, die dann irgendwie Tim Pritlove ist blöd oder da gab es mal Leute, die was Blödes über Tim Pritlove gesagt haben, die das in den Artikel reinschreiben. Das ist für die Betroffenen meist nicht so toll.
Zweitens, ich gehe da proaktiv gegen Freunde und sage so viele blöde Sachen über mich selber, da kann keiner mit sein.
Das ist eine Methode, das ist die Klaus-Eck-Methode. Also, ja, für die Betroffenen ist das oft ein Problem. Und zweitens, für die Leser ist es auch manchmal ein Problem. Ein schönes Beispiel war jetzt auch der Chung, der Hackercocktail, der aus der deutschen Wikipedia gelöscht wurde. Ich hätte ihn nicht gelöscht, ich hatte kein Problem mit dem Artikel, aber ich habe das verfolgt. Und es war spannend zu sehen, es gab tatsächlich ein wesentliches Problem mit diesem Chung-Artikel, nämlich es gibt quasi keinen Chung. Die Leute haben versucht, dann diesen Artikel zu erweitern und Quellen heranzuziehen. Und die Bandbreite der Rezepturen, die angeführt wurde, lag irgendwo zwischen Kuba Libre und Caripirinha. Die Limetten waren entbehrlich, mal war es Crushed Ice, mal waren es Eiswürfel, mal war es Salzrand, mal war Zucker drin. Sprich, es waren sehr unterschiedliche Cocktails, die unter diesem Namen geführt werden. Was noch kein Problem wäre, in der englischen Wikipedia wirkt dieser Satz sehr anregend wegen Alkohol und Zucker usw. Dann hat auch jemand eine Studie gezückt, wo vor diesen Cocktails mit Koffein drin gewarnt wurde, dass die gesundheitlich nicht so ganz ohne sind. Das ist dann eine Information, die für Leser wichtig wäre, aber die dann im deutschen Artikel niemals rüber gekommen wäre.
Warum wäre die im deutschen Artikel nicht rüber gekommen?
Naja, der Artikel stand schon über ein Jahr drin. Die Leute, die ein Interesse am Junk hatten, waren einfach nur Fans. Sie hatten kein Interesse daran, dass irgendjemand ihren Lieblingscocktail irgendwie madisch macht.
Das ist aber jetzt nur eine These. Es war jetzt nicht wirklich, dass es da so ein Edit war, um dieses Detail gab, oder doch?
Dieses Detail wurde jetzt gerade in den englischen Artikel eingeführt, nachdem es diese riesen Debatte gab.
Okay, dann ist das jetzt von dir aber erstmal nur eine Behauptung, dass das jetzt ein Problem hätte sein können in dem deutschen Artikel, der jetzt nicht mehr existiert.
Es ist ein, sagen wir mal, alle Wahrscheinlichkeit spricht dafür, weil es halt diesen Artikel lange gab. Der Artikel wurde ja nochmal in dieser Artikel-Werkstatt gestellt, im Benutzernahmensraum, wo sich dann tatsächlich zehn Leute bemüht haben, noch Quellen heranzuschaffen, die irgendwie zitierfähig sind, wo dann tatsächlich auch ein Blog zitiert wurde, was ein Chunk-Rezept ohne Clubmater enthielt. Das ist ja Frevel. Ja, wo ich mich dann gefragt habe, um Gottes Willen, gibt es den Chunk überhaupt?
Der Chunk ist wirklich ein interessantes Beispiel, weil man versucht ja nun in der Wikipedia, die Dinge sozusagen, jetzt sind wir doch wieder bei der Relevanzdebatte, danach zu bemessen, ist denn das außerhalb unserer Netzrealität überhaupt schon mal berichtet worden? Und man wehrt sich gegen Wissenserstellungen im Rahmen der Wikipedia so nach dem Motto, es wurde ja da reingeschrieben, also gibt es das? Andererseits wissen wir natürlich auch, es gibt mittlerweile so viele Meme, die wirklich eine kulturelle Realität darstellen, die aus dem Netz kommen und die sicherlich auch über das Netz hinaus irgendwann nochmal eine Bedeutung haben. Und wenn es irgendwie so ein Netzcocktail ist, ich meine, ich kenne die Geschichte vom Chunk. Ich weiß, dass das jetzt nichts ist, was irgendwie in Südamerika auf Feuerland auch gemixt wird oder so. Trotzdem existiert dieses Ding. Und es existierte auch schon, bevor er irgendwie in dieser Hakka-Kultur da eine Rolle gespielt hat. Von daher empfinde ich das schlicht und ergreifend als schade, dass darüber jetzt nicht berichtet werden kann und offensichtlich es auch nicht möglich ist, dieses Wissen hereinzutragen in der besten Absicht. Dass man einfach weiß, ja hier, da gibt es irgendwie eine Variante, die auch definitiv eine große Fanzahl hat, die allein schon deshalb für mich relevant ist, weil eben es Leute gibt, die das halt einfach toll finden. Es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt jede beliebige Getränk-Kombination toll gefunden wird von irgendjemand.
Ja, das ist der große Grenzbereich des Wissens. Das ist auch die Frage der Medienkompetenz. Wie viel Medienkompetenz traut man den Menschen zu? Und vertraut man darauf, dass Menschen, wenn sie Wikipedia-Artikel lesen, dass sie schon wissen, dass darauf sollte ich mich jetzt nicht hundertprozentig verlassen. Ich sollte den Links folgen. Wenn ich die Debatte um die Wikipedia sehe, Links folgen, selbst recherchieren, ist selbst in dem Hardcore-Bereich der Netz-Szene wird einfach nicht mehr gemacht. Wenn ich mir die Ansätze von Chris Köhntopf sehe, der seine Usenet-Erfahrungen in Regelwerke umzusetzen versucht, die als vermeintliche Rettung zur Wikipedia taugen sollen, bin ich sehr skeptisch, weil diese Ansätze gab es sehr oft schon lange und sie haben im Endeffekt kaum funktioniert. Zum Beispiel hat man versucht jetzt einen Verlässlichkeitsindikator zu schaffen, indem man Textpassagen einfärbt, die kürzlich geändert wurden. Klingt ja an sich logisch. Wenn etwas umstritten ist, dann wird es oft editiert. Dann machen wir mal eine Warnfarbe davor bzw. ein Warnschild. Das Problem war, ich habe mir jetzt angesehen, wie das konkret aussieht. Bei Angela Merkel wird ihr Vorname rot markiert und dass sie CDU-Bundesvorsitzende ist und dass sie Kanzlerin ist, wurde rot markiert. Weil an der Formulierung gefeilt wurde und nicht an den Fakten selbst. Und die Frage nach Automatismen, ich bin da sehr skeptisch, dass es mehr als Hilfsmittel geben kann. Wissen ist und bleibt Arbeit. Du durftest früher nicht alles glauben, was in der Lokalzeitung steht. Du darfst heute noch weniger glauben, was in deinem Twitterbekanntenkreis verbreitet wurde. Wenn du tatsächlich Wert legst auf Informationen, musst du Arbeit investieren. Das ist eine andere Arbeit als früher, die du investieren musst. Vielleicht ist es sogar mehr Arbeit als früher, die du investieren musst, weil es sehr viel mehr Information gibt und weil du sehr viel mehr suchen musst. Und weil wir alle unter Informationsüberflutung leiden.
In welchen Konstellationen kann denn Informationsgewinnung und Informationsbewertung dann überhaupt effektiv stattfinden? Wir haben jetzt so verschiedenste Spannungsfelder, die totale Öffentlichkeit, einst gepriesen als das 1000-Augen-Prinzip, was so viele Leute sich anschauen. Das kann nicht falsch sein, weil jeder Fehler würde ja bald entdeckt werden. Das ist auch so ein Mythos der Open-Source-Entwicklung. Auf der anderen Seite klingt durch, wir brauchen eine geschlossene Benutzergruppe, damit sie nicht überspammt wird und so weiter. Wir brauchen vielleicht auch eine geschlossene Benutzergruppe, damit wir Regeln erarbeiten können, die dann auch eingehalten werden, damit man sich auf die Arbeit der anderen verlassen kann. Dann gibt es aber dann wieder nächste Kritik. Na ja, wenn die Gruppe so geschlossen ist, dann bleibt sie auch so geschlossen, weil sie sich dann nicht mehr automatisch erneuert und quasi in ihren eigenen Regeln festfährt und so. Dann ist es irgendwie so richtig keine Lösung zu geben.
Es ist ein ständiger Widerstreit. Es ist wie immer die goldene Mitte, die zählt. Wikipedia hat sich natürlich in den letzten Jahren sehr auseinander bzw. sehr abgekapselt. Allein dadurch, dass das Niveau der Artikel sehr viel höher wurde, aber dadurch, dass die Software auch nicht mitgewachsen ist mit diesen vielfältigen Anforderungen an die Wikipedia. Zum Beispiel, was sehr oft ignoriert wird, ist Wikipedia bindet sehr viel Mesh-up ein. Mesh-ups verlangen aber eine sehr, sehr strenge Disziplin.
Was man so mit Wikipedia bindet?
Jetzt zum Beispiel ein aktuelles Projekt ist, Open-Street-Maps einzubinden. Um Open-Street-Maps einzubinden, braucht man aber eine sehr, sehr strenge Disziplin, um Koordinatenangaben richtig einzubauen. Es muss eine bestimmte Form geben, diese Koordinatenangaben sinnvoll einzubinden und dann muss gesehen werden, dass die Informationen tatsächlich sinnvoll sind. Also wenn ich jetzt vom Kölner Dom eine Karte einbinde, dass da nicht das Autobahnkreuz Köln zu sehen ist, sondern der Umkreis vom Domplatz oder ISBN-Nummern usw. Das sind alles sehr, sehr strikte Vorgaben, die auch sehr viel Nutzen bringen, aber die natürlich auch die freien Mitarbeiter ausschließen, die mal eben ein Komma korrigieren wollen. Copyright ist auch ein großes Problem, wenn da Leute Sachen hochladen, die eventuell nicht ganz astrein sind. Da überhaupt einen Prozess aufzubauen, der Copyright einigermaßen verlässlich absichert, das ist schwer.
Kommen wir mal weg von Wikipedia und vielleicht noch mal zum Schluss auf die Urfrage, die ja so war, mit was bedeutet, Medienkompetenz auszuleben heute. Was sollte man sozusagen berücksichtigen? Jetzt kann nicht jeder immer die ganze Zeit allem hinterher recherchieren. Das ist einfach unrealistisch, das zu erwarten. Fragt sich, was so ein gutes Rüstzeug sein könnte, um generell erst mal ein bisschen hoax-resistenter zu sein?
Gesunder Menschenverstand ist ein großes Mittel, um Hoaxes zu begegnen.
Eigentlich heißt es aber, generell erst mal alles, immer allem zu misstrauen. Also das Vertrauen entsteht eigentlich durch generelles Misstrauen? Kann man das sagen?
Das ist meine Lebensarte, aber ich würde sie nicht jedem empfehlen.
Okay, da kommt dann vielleicht wirklich der Journalist bei raus.
Ja, also ich schalte eigentlich grundsätzlich auf, um Gottes Willen, da muss doch was falsch dran sein. Und das kann niemand, der nicht davon lebt, durchhalten. Mein Ratschlag ist, Versuch herauszufinden, was tatsächlich für dich relevant ist. Du wirst nicht die große Weltverschwörung von 9.11 oder von Klimaerwärmung lösen können. Du kannst aber dafür sorgen, dass du erfährst, wie ist das jetzt mit der Umweltzone in meiner Stadt? Wie ist das jetzt mit den Steuern, die sich demnächst ergeben? Man muss eine gewisse Breite seiner Informationsquellen sicherstellen, was zurzeit auch gerade im Netzkreis etwas vernachlässigt wird, nach meinem Eindruck. Und das wird sich auch wieder etwas einpendeln. Das große Stichwort ist auch wieder Geoinformationen. Es besteht eine gewisse Hoffnung, dass quasi die soziale Funktion, die von der Lokalpresse, die einfach bestand und für die es noch keinen adäquaten Ersatz gibt, nachzubilden ist bzw. dass wir Techniken und soziale Mechanismen finden, wieder etwas nachzubilden, was bei den alten Medien doch nicht ganz schlecht war.
So ein Nachbarschaftsprinzip?
Nicht nur Nachbarschaft, sondern auch Leute, die sich aktiv drum kümmern, das rauszusuchen, was für dich interessant sein kann, sein muss.
Und denkst du, dass das Modell eines Citizen-Reporters, eines Bürgerjournalisten etwas sein kann, was tragfähig ist? Man sozusagen aus seiner Community heraus sich für journalistische Arbeit zumindest in einem bestimmten Maße finanzieren lassen kann?
Sagen wir es mal so, Bürgerjournalismus ist absolut nichts Neues. Ich habe mein erstes Lokalpraktikum mit 17 gemacht, da standen dann sehr oft die Bürger mitten in der Redaktion und haben uns gesagt, was denn Sache ist, die ganze Arbeit im Lokaljournalismus bestand, darin mit Bürgern zu sprechen bzw. denen auch Möglichkeiten zur Veröffentlichung zu geben. Es gab dann auch das Schulprojekt immer, dass Kinder eine Zeitungsseite gestalten können. Das ist heute sehr viel einfacher. Wir müssen einen neuen gesellschaftlichen Konsens finden, wie wir mit Datenschutz bzw. mit Informationen umgehen. Allein dieses Feld der Persönlichkeitsrechte ist beim Bürgerjournalismus eine ungelöste Frage. Wenn ich über meinen Nachbar berichte, soll das 15 Jahre später noch da stehen, auf das der Nachbar dann eventuell auf der Titelseite der Bildzeitung steht als Opfer oder sonst was. Bürgerjournalismus hat natürlich seine Berechtigung, inwieweit er quasi die Alternative zum Mainstream-Journalismus sein kann. Da bin ich sehr skeptisch bzw. das ging immer Hand in Hand. Und wie es in Zukunft in Hand geht, das ist eine ungelöste Frage. Wir müssen da aufpassen, was passiert. Wir müssen auch darauf achten, dass wir nicht in der Euphorie quasi alles über den Haufen werfen, was früher sich herausgebildet hat.
Ja, dann muss ich sagen, Torsten, wir sind jetzt hier am Ende angekommen. 1,5 Stunden durchgeschwatzt. Vielen Dank.
Ich bedanke mich auch.
Vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Ja, das war Chaosradio Express aus Köln. Mit Blick auf Kölner Dom hier. Tolle Aussicht. Genießen wir hier gerade. Sehr hübsch. Und für mich geht es heute noch weiter auf Reisen. Ich setze mich gleich wieder in den Express und werde dann daran arbeiten. Was das nächste Thema ist, was natürlich, wie ihr es gewohnt seid, nicht verraten wird, das war jetzt aber erstmal unser Sermon hier zur Medienkompetenz. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf die Kommentare zu dieser Sendung, weil ich denke, hier war dann noch sehr viel Diskussionswürdiges und Weiterführendes am Start. So, jetzt sag ich Amen, danke nochmal und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.
Auf Wiedersehen!